he had originally played it really
oppositionally then i'm a rat you know
angry at him and i said you know since
we're dramatizing a transition
i think it'd be much better if you
realize you can't communicate to this
guy
can you tell us some of the challenges
you faced directing the second episode
of the sopranos
yeah the sopranos as was interesting i
had
met david chase when he was a showrunner
on northern exposure which was a
wonderful show in the uh
in the mid 90s which i i really
recommend people seek out
and i had i
david then went on to direct the pilot
for the sopranos
and uh there were several months before
hbo decided to make it as a series
and i was very uh
honored and happy that david called me
to direct
the first episode that would air
following the pilot and they came so the
company came together i think six or
nine months after the pilot had been the
original pilot had been shot
so uh when i saw the pilot i just said
oh my god this is the greatest thing
i've ever seen and uh
uh and there were there were there were
the challenges it was almost like
shooting a pilot again because it was a
whole new company coming together and it
was the first episode and james
gandolfini for example who had made a
wonderful career as a kind of a
part-time player in a lot of different
shows was not used to a television
schedule i remember the first scene we
shot he was ready to call it a day and
we said no no james we got four more
scenes today
but one of the interesting uh things in
that episode it was called 46 long and
it's i directed other episodes of the
sopranos that may be my favorite one so
uh
uh
if you haven't seen it i really
recommend it but uh among the some of
the more memorable moments in it was
the the the the episode actually was
about
tony having to commit his mother uh
played by olivia played by nancy
marchand to a uh assisted living
facility
and one thing i'll share that david
chase has spoken about is that uh and
what really informed the series and gave
it a lot of real great inner life is
that david
had a mother
that was the model for livia a real kind
of sociopathic misanthropic
human being that
was very challenging for him just as you
see nancy marchand's behavior is so
challenging for tony soprano
and in this episode
he's trying to convince her to go into
green grove retirement community and uh
one of the things that finally uh
convinces him that he has to force her
to is that there's a there's a very
funny scene in the in the episode where
she's dropping her friend off
at home and she drives this big green
honker of a car up a steep driveway and
the friend just gets out and get leans
down to pick up the newspaper and nancy
marshall looks behind her thinks she's
backing out but then presses the
accelerator and runs into the
into the friend who falls right back
into the windshield and it was it was
one of those moments fortunately the
stunt person was all right but uh it was
one of those moments that it just
sometimes it happens that
fade is with you and the elements just
come together was a beautiful fun stunt
but one of the challenges i had and i
cite this in the book because i
i have a chapter entitled creating the
world of your story which is another way
of saying creating contextualizing
things
because context contextualizing is so
important to bring the audience along to
acquaint them with what are the
conditions that
they're being acquainted with it permits
them to understand what's happening if
you don't do that work
your things can happen and they don't
land because people don't understand in
what context they're happening or what's
what's going on so that part of much of
the job of directing for me
is to is to kind of fill in things for
an audience of you know as
as unobtrusively as as you know without
calling attention to it i'm acquainting
them with the rules of this world and
and the situ the specifics of the
situation
and in the pilot many people i'm sure
will recall you know tony was revealed
as suffering from panic attacks and he
had he had uh sought out
uh lorraine uh bronco playing dr melfi
as help and that was one of the genius
conceits of the whole show that mob boss
having
talk therapy
so in this episode there was one
sequence where
i want to talk about it just because it
was an example of finding a way to
contextualize something to give the
audience a deeper experience of it
and
there was a an early sequence when tony
is approached at his place of work
he goes into work and
he's having to juggle many things he's
having to juggle uh trying to reach a
important business partner and his
assist his guy who's answering the phone
being totally inept and cutting him off
and him worried about that he's having
to adjust with various people coming up
to him silvio and christopher and with
their own their own needs and saying to
tone we've got to do this and they're
all they're trying to please him but
they all feel entitled to his attention
so that was one of the things i wanted
to do i wanted to create
the sense of the stress tony lived with
so i would direct all so one of the
things i did was to direct all the
actors to make sure when they approached
tony that they felt completely entitled
to take all of his time to hear the
particulars their intention being to
impress their boss but they're not aware
that comedically they're actually
pissing him off a lot because they're
not allowing him to get to the 12 other
things he has to do so that was kind of
happening and he also is having to find
the
his wife carmella has asked him to help
help out junior's uh junior high school
teacher who had his saturn car stolen
can't we try to find it so he's having
to please carmela he's having to please
this business associate he's having to
address all of his you know you know all
of his uh underlings needs
and he's you can see he's just tightly
wound but he's doing a really great job
of it and uh until he gets a call from
his mother
and that's the show-stopping centerpiece
of the sequence when you get to see the
dynamic
and the between olivia and tony all
right so i wanted to create
a context for understanding that the
first
gambit was of course to give everybody
this kind of entitlement as they
approach him and not responding to any
of his cues that he has anything else to
think about
but with olivia i wanted to kind of
somehow uh
create in the audience an awareness of
how difficult a personality she was for
him and i thought you know this is a
strip club this is the bada bing as
everybody knows
most people and uh and there were these
new dancers on the dance floor you know
doing the pole dancing and i thought it
would be really interesting if i when
tony takes the call from his mother
if i position him in such a way that
these new dancers are dancing behind his
head
and that also affected my lens choices
because uh
you know to shoot say a shot this size
on a person a close-up you can do it
with a long lens which means you see
very little of the background behind
because it's telephoto
or you can bring the camera in really
close and have a wide lens which means
you see
you know the whole room
so i chose a wide lens to shoot tony
you know answering this call from his
mother
who you know misses no opportunity to
guilt-trip him about his inattention and
while he's talking to her and she's
being very very difficult these nude
women are dancing behind his head and i
don't know that anybody would have made
this connection but i think subliminally
you make the connection that when he's
talking to this woman who invokes these
kind of primal feminine forces that are
so difficult for him i thought having
these new dancers behind his head as
he's talking to his mother would somehow
humanize tony and like
it would it would you know make him the
child again and
against you know
with these these feminine figures
powerful feminine figures kind of
dancing in his head that he's powerless
to defend against
so uh that was how i filmed it and i
thought that uh you know and then the
scene was great i mean olivia winds up
setting fire to her kitchen and tony
doesn't know what to do he says stop
everything he's doing and
run you know get carmela to go over to
the house so it's kicked off the episode
in an interesting way but i thought it
was by contextualizing
the moment in a subtle way that wasn't
scripted
it was a way you know it's a it's a
touch that a director has opportunity to
bring if you can think of it that way
you know there was another instance of
that i'll cite and another great show i
was fortunate to direct the wire
i directed several of several seasons of
the wire and i
directed an episode in four of the five
seasons
and in the last season i directed an
episode called transitions
and one and that showed various
characters transitioning to different
uh levels of responsibility or within
the hierarchy either of the drug culture
or the police department
and you know several climatic thing hap
things happened one of which was prop
joe one of the beloved
characters beloved he was a tough drug
dealer but he was a great character he's
executed in this episode by the
character marlow so you see
him transitioning
to the end of his life while marlow
transitions to ascend to the top of the
drug hierarchy there are various
transitions like that happening
throughout and one of them
was between two characters who were kind
of comedic relief a lot of the time but
also
genuine characters in their arm right to
police
carver and herc
and uh
herc the previous season they'd gotten
and they'd had a lot of misadventures
together we'd seen over various seasons
and finally
herc had been drummed out of the force
for some indiscretion he had done
carver
in this season has been promoted to
become a sergeant so he's having to see
things from the other side of the desk
in a little different way
and
what happens in the episode is that um
he he sees that he has more
responsibility and that he can no longer
look the other way and one of his
one of the
police guys working beneath him has done
something very bad he's actually
attacked a school teacher in the midst
of a routine drug bust
and
he's been cited by the department and
the police his own troops are gathering
around him okay this is how we're going
to do it you know we'll tell him you
know
the guy was being obstructionist which
we know he wasn't he was a simple
bystander
and
carver confronts
the character as colicchio as a
character for those of fans of the wire
and he tells kaliko he's trying to help
him and he says okay
this is what we're going to do we're
going to say this happened this happened
this happened this happened and
collected says nah [ __ ] him he was an
[ __ ] and i'm glad i did what i did
and carver just looks at them and just
says
okay you're toast i'm turning you in
and collectio says then you are a rat
and
garbage just says
then i'm a rat
and i'll say this this wasn't the point
i was going to get to get to another
point but that was fun it was a fun
moment for me because i i realized
i helped the actor with carver with that
line because he had originally played it
really oppositionally then i'm a rat you
know angry at him and i said you know
since we're dramatizing a transition
i think it'd be much better if you
realize you can't communicate to this
guy with this guy you're not you see in
his refusal to take responsibility
that you
he's lost you so let him think whatever
he wants
don't oppose him like to change his view
and he just threw it away says then i'm
a rat knowing i'm not a rat you're an
[ __ ]
and uh
and so that was kind of a nice moment
but the point i was trying to get to was
that there was a scene where the other
police officers try to get carver to
reconsider not to turn in kalikio so
they enlist the help of his former
former partner herc who's no longer in
the force and they get herc to meet with
him in the parking lot of the precinct
to say try to talk some sense in him
come on appeal come on we're brothers
here don't don't do this
so there's a scene where the two of them
are having a beer in the uh
precinct parking lot
and again trying to contextualize i put
i put uh a symbol of herc's new he's
he's now signed on with a corrupt lawyer
and he's gone for the money
and he's driving a mercedes so i put a
mercedes right there and so carver is
sitting on the hood of a police car with
with herc on the police car but you can
see the the mercedes so you get a sense
of okay this is how things have changed
and in the course of the discussion
what's going to happen is herc is going
to say come on come on what do you think
maybe cut him some slack you know is it
really so bad
and carver doesn't answer him directly
instead he spends a story which we've
seen in in a previous season
herc had
had missed
his head had not acted on something he
he needed to act on in order to save one
of the most endearing characters a young
boy named randy who had snitched
and uh helped the police in a way he
should have because it was a horrific
thing that he witnessed
but he made it very clear you can't tell
anyone that this has happened or i'm i'm
dead
and
he they set up a set of signals that
would happen if it looks like he's about
to be
outed and the police were going to
correct you know somehow create a
different impression and herc missed the
signal
so the boy randy wound up getting
labeled as a snitch and he wasn't killed
but he was sent to a reform school where
he was beaten every day and he was
totally deadened as a character and
carver knows this and instead of
answering kirk directly he says
you know randy
you know that character randy and herc
says yeah so what he says well you know
we let him down you let him down he said
yeah so what he says well it matters is
what it all matters
so you get that sense that in this
moment you're watching a transition
happen that hurt that that carver has
now accepted that there are consequences
to the way we act
and the force of how he did it simply
shows herc that he's right and herc
instead of transforming
carver is himself transformed and he
says you do what you have to do turn
koikyo in it's the right thing to do
don't don't
don't don't care at all what the other
guys think about it's the right thing to
do okay so that's the transition that's
what we're
dramatizing and it's a powerful scene
and it would have played great and they
did great but i was thinking what can i
do
to contextualize this to give it perhaps
greater depth and resonance
and i and during prep i remembered a
previous episode of the wire and one of
the great things about the wire and the
storytelling and the wire david simon
and ed burns david simon created the
show
they never spoke down to the audience
and they never never felt they had to
recapitulate things you know in so many
stories if there's a story point that
references something from two seasons
ago
either they'll show it previously on and
they'll show that or they'll have
characters talk about reset it so that
people have it in their minds when they
watch it here the wire never did that if
you missed something in a season you
missed it and then you know but i had
seen something in a previous season
where
david simon had scripted
that when the police exit
into the precinct parking lot they're
drinking beer they ritually would hurl
their beer cans or bottles up onto the
roof
and the reason he put that in is he had
he had embedded with the baltimore
homicide department and he loved and
this was a real thing they did so he
loved injecting these authentic touches
into the wire
and i remembered this scene where
these guys apropos of nothing in
particular but they just had a beer or
drank and said hey and they threw it up
on the roof
and i thought
okay how might it be an interesting
thing to start the scene from the
rooftop
and have a camera gliding across all
these discarded cans and bottles
and seeing in the frame down below
carver and herx seated on the car small
figures
and it would perhaps contextualize
what was happening here by create
contextualize this as a kind of ritual
space this is a place where policemen
gather and let their hair down and act
and just you know speak truth to one
another
and so that's what i did and i had i had
in prep i asked the prop department to
go make sure you collect tons of cans
and bottles and all that and they did it
you know they were you know and we had a
special you know
we had to get the camera up on the roof
and make sure it was safe and at a low
camera angle and i just just i didn't
quite didn't say anything about it but i
just started the shot going over these
these discarded cans and bottles so the
hope was that the transition that
audiences would watch happening would
have a deeper significance because it
would be as if it's a transition within
the culture itself because we were in
this ritualized space didn't
didn't cut back to it didn't do anything
else but it just set a context for those
who really were careful viewers of the
show i think they'd experience the scene
a little more deeply